dog no wonder I've been seeing so many
kids pedaling their bikes and I'm
thinking about it but like barely
pedaling they're fake but going fast
barely fast you notice they're barely P
going like this cuz they are going fast
they're going faster than your car dude
you're like what the they're going like
this like and they're going like 30 m
hour like
[Laughter]
[Music]
[__] be careful boys have a very
special thing to share with our lovely
JK news audience and that is that our
friend Ron skang is running for mayor of
Irvine mayor of
Irvine okay that's amazing you got your
wave down how how much of a chance do
you got wait whoa what's your point that
hold it did you have to check if it's
loaded for I need to bring my security
team wait how did this all come about
again like how so Random you were just
knocking fools out and they're like he
should run the city yeah if you can
fight good you could probably run City
good dude I didn't know it was adjacent
like I trust you it's uh thank you it's
uh It Started from the community service
thing you know I've been doing my whole
life since I've been doing martial arts
and then we did that senior fight back
thing and that blew up and then I met a
bunch of politicians through that a m of
the people for real
people and you know I met a bunch of
politicians in that process and a bunch
of people started like elbowing me like
hey you should buy politics you should
buy politics and I'm extreme with
everything so I went down a rabbit hole
and found some a bunch of data and then
reach out to a bunch of my contacts and
I was like dude we can actually win this
thing I'm like let's expand this
community service let's make more of an
impact and then now we're we're like
elbow deep into this and we're going to
we're actually going to win this thing
it's going to be crazy so when you win
May when you win mayor are you still
going to come on the show or you can't
probably what do you mean I'll be on the
show whenever you guys want me who are
you up against Mr Mayor of Irvine I'm
just going to say right now cuz you
already going to win it who can we
badmouth immediately yeah I'm going
against uh Larry Egan all right smear
campaign let's create one all right here
we go JK smear campaign
yeah [__] you white boy he's white right
is he white yeah oh yeah say it again
I'm not going to say we need some Asians
up in this [__] you know what
I'm saying and then the other person is
actually Asian her name is Tammy
Kimmy we don't need no Koreans running
[__] man Anthony went to high school
with Tammy we need the Vietnamese oh you
went to high school there yeah that's
what he said Sunny Hills High yeah she
went to S Hills
eye what said he went to high school
with her I say that but yeah if that's
the part of the smear campaign I that's
what makes her look that my whole Life's
a smear so I don't think it is I'm
Anthony Lee and I endorse this oh so you
got so it's three people running you
Debbie and Larry you said
Debbie did you say Debbie Kim Tammy Kim
Tammy Kim oh you know that might be
you're still thinking about white people
dude that might be a good strategy like
when you I don't know if you guys do
debates but if you refer to your people
you're running against and you always
get their name wrong what you mean like
see I can't even remember you cuz not
memorable yeah like Debbie all so um
they're what Democrats Republicans they
both they're both Democrats they're both
Democrats they're
Boo whoa yeah they've been in the game
for like a super long time so they have
they've got they've got so they like
fart dust what that's interesting cuz I
always thought Irvine was a republican
City and it yes super liberal it's
Republican presenting it used to be they
used to be the headquarters of the
Republican part in Southern California
but back in the boomer generation cuz
all them Asians are Republicans for sure
but now all these like young cats cuz
when I was these ant eaters no that when
I was visiting my friends in nervine and
all that like I I remember being very
red over there even during that's cuz
you a boomer even during Co all the gyms
that were locked down in LA everyone
would drive to OC to train it was almost
like a different state it was like yeah
there you could eat outside no one was
wearing a mask and then just in La like
all gyms all [__] everything shut
down I remember in in Pasadena in La
they'll be like put your mask on I'm
like all right fine and I put the mask
on get into the restaurant walk two
steps and get to my table take it off
right but then in Orange County if I
have a mask on they're like there's air
you can breathe take it off and I'm like
what the [__] dude yeah then I was
fortunate cuz I live in Orange County so
there was during that whole thing there
was one week where I actually didn't eat
out um and then right after that week we
just went back to eating out cuz there's
restaurant are like nope we're staying
open we're staying open what the f I'm a
vote for you man so how does that work
if the if the state if Irvine had that
kind of response but they're still like
wildly Democratic how does that work I
think it's they're Democratic I thought
that with the OC with the Republican
that's what I was thinking Orange County
as a whole is Republican but Irvine
specifically is very liberal and I think
it's because of UCI UCI is 90%
Democratic and they have a 90% voter
turnout z z this guy knows his number
that means you know why it's because
most University kids they're hella
political but they're too lazy to vote
that's one of the funniest stats out
there because senior citizens actually
like turn to vote like they actually
make it but like these days there's more
active politically active youth yeah 90%
90% turnout dude but also you're you're
going to school with a bunch of Asians
that actually do their homework so you
know they're going to all do what
they're supposed to do which is vote but
they learn the wrong [__] or join dance
teams they're going to go
that Biden still somehow get do you know
how you're pulling so far like are you
like ahead by how many percent oh so
it's a it's a different type of game so
like mirror sounds cool and all but it's
actually not that big of a deal in the
scheme of things cuz like I'm not going
to change gun laws or anything like that
like I'm going to help make ebikes safer
for people you know like for me if I can
change that that's a huge win for me how
do you make it safer you know um well
I'm not big on like forcing you to do
stuff but I'm big on educating you and
incentivizing you to do stuff you know
that's different cuz when you make
somebody do something they don't really
want to do it so like even if it's good
for them yeah it was good for them
right's going to run our country brother
I see it down the line we had to make
killing illegal right cuz uh it wasn't
legal illegal before yeah yeah religion
is illegal and then by law it's illegal
um but they had to put it a cuz people
were killing even though they knew it
was wrong and so they had a they had a
regulate and so this ebik thing if you
had the regulate it's going to be tough
cuz people were going to find out ways
around but I randomly te up with this
company called super
73 I love that dude I have one of those
too dude I randomly like connected with
one of the founders he's a he's an Asian
dude too how do you team just team
up how do you just team I need a team I
don't have any teaming up with anybody
let's team how do we team up with just
teams and [__] like you got these
[__] chairs how do you just team up
with people to just it's easy oh got do
is calling me like literally even this
chair thing life baby yes thank you guys
we are a team Bart but all good good
fuckups though we all pretty much do
yeah all of us have you just never use
them you just never call us when I was
going to UC Irvine there's a guy running
for a class president and he promised
there to be a Chipotle in the in the
school quad and he never did it are you
going to be that kind of I'm I think the
when I do my first like speech thingy
for a debate and all that be like if you
vote for me I will make all your dreams
come true oh I'm voting for you I
believe oh the conflict on my personal
dream will too offset all of those
conflictions are you still going to pick
up the homeless lady that used to hang
out in front of the Jack in the Box and
mve ver to Santa Ana oh yeah you that's
what the cops would always do uh dude
randomly I'm doing this thing I'm
surveying the homeless so on the I think
at the end of this month I have to wake
up at like 3:00 a.m. I'm going to go
through uh South County at 4:30 a.m. I'm
going to run through the cities and find
out all the encampments you're doing
like a visual census of everything
sensus I'm going to interview them
you're actually going to do your job
who is this guy are you going to do it
on a super 73 cuz that's good teaming up
I might I have to ask I have to ask for
that um if they'll let me damn dude
you're going to actually do work as a
politician yeah I'm actually doing this
for community service yeah so when do
you have time to actually work cuz like
politicians usually have like their real
real job and then like they have like
they're like hey let me just do this
kind of ribbon and [__] pretend like
I'm digging some [__] you know just 90%
I agree yeah but I've I've aligned
myself with the % that actually want to
do stuff which is really cool and
they're the ones that push me to get
scared you're going to get assassinated
yeah like this motherfucker's working
who's going to kill me for changing
ebike policy oh yeah [__] Debbie C
puffy will dude big bicycles is going to
come after you right Big Brother bicycle
they're going to
bike like you're going to have [__]
big Huffy big diamond big the FR comes
yeah [__] big Schwin big swins of SC
first I didn't think they were going to
work with me because they like oh this
guy wants to change ebike it's going to
lower our sales I was like no man I'm
not trying to make laws I'm trying to
make incentives so we're going to put
together a safety certification program
and if you get that certification you
get like a discount off of super 73 and
dude some of these bikes are like $8,000
so to get even 10% off is it a big
problem like people like cause an
accident heck yeah dude last month I had
two kids I saw my own eyes get hit on
bikes cuz they're doing wheelies and
these kids they don't really know the
road loss yet you know they don't know
about on coming traffic like what is
oncoming traffic doesn't that mean they
like deserve it to die you can't be may
he said hit not killed you got to listen
Debbie Debbie jump into
conclusions get that dust out of ear so
tell us straight up like what would what
would the JK news audience that loves
you be able to do to help you move to
Irvine just vote for you could register
as a resident in Irvine uh go vote that
would be very go vote cuz you know damn
well you see ain't watching us anymore
you heard him go get a condo on jamere
road and then jamere that's probably
Prime real EST dud I like Irvine I got a
couple of friends in
Irvine that place is unreal dude I I
just found out there's public TK I I
used to think it was only kindergarten
and there's public TK now which is a
transition it's like it's like before
prek it's confusing It's Like Preschool
TK and then kindergarten yeah so there's
an in between now I didn't know there
was an in further they're learning but
they're to categorize it all into one
they're they
thems that part I'm cool with I'm like
okay cool forther learning but it wasn't
even advertised I had no idea that was
even available until one of my
politician friends um told me he like
hey there's a there's a he almost
Whispers like there's a there's a public
TK program I'm like why don't people
know about this I'm like what the heck I
feel like there's so many programs that
people don't even know about it's cuz
they're
lazy even if the program's there you
think they're going to do it dude the
budgets the grants that like cities
counties and States get is insane like
it's insane the amount of money dude
there's professional Grant Riders dog
they just sit there right [__] grant
money all day collect col there's Grant
managers that make money from finding
you grants like their Fe be like 30%
yeah they'll be like hey uh they they
approach us for a nonprofit too like hey
if we find you $100,000 Grant we get 30%
I was like well that's more than we
would have gotten without you right so
like that's their I used to go to elac
which is East LA Community College right
here and I think I made like
3g's in just writing essays cuz if you
go on the financial aid department on
the board there's all these scholarships
you could sign up for so it'll be like
scholarship for the blind scholarship
for minorities that want to teach I do
that I'm going to win this for sure all
I looked at the lady and I was like like
do people actually win this cuz each
one's like 500 bucks she goes honestly
if you just write the essay you probably
win cuz no one even replied you got to
come in every day with a [__] stick
yeah I want to be a teacher and then I'm
like yeah like I have really bad
eyesight and preventing me from learning
and I was just getting $500 checks and I
got [__] kicker sound system my
godi just go write some [__] essays
700 Watts bro but there his money just
around but people don't yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's going to go somewhere you
could [__] ride this essay hey bro
that's pretty sick man that's cool so
you're you're running you're running as
a as a as a Democrat Republican I'm
running as NP p no party no party
preference all you're going to be like
Robert Robert F Kennedy independent
Robert F Kennedy yeah well only because
only because strategically if I pick a
side but there's two parts generally in
politics you have to pick a side because
if you don't have their support like you
have no one's going to back you up no
one's going to back you up right and
then um but for Irvine it's so crazy
crazy like liberal out there um that
Democrats don't want to support me cuz
they're already backing the other two
people and if uh if I if I join the
Republican party if they even want me
right cuz they can't you can't just be
like hey can I join you guys yeah come
in they're like they have to decide if
you're a good fit or not oh and you're
just like [__] you I make my own lane
yeah third party baby I like third party
I like it you know why cuz it's like you
don't have to do what they tell you to
do you do your own [__] [__] you just
rarely win right yeah so the chances
stereotypically of winning are very low
because not Jessie Ventura baby from a
fighter to fighter come on what did you
see that made you go like wa we can
actually win it as NPP yeah you know me
um well the that decision was based upon
my uh my campaign manager and
Consultants that I have and so i' I've
got Consultants that yeah dude we have
like a legit team it's freaking crazy
that's what the heck we need a team the
team the theme of the podcast today like
his team is [__] people that are like
they do crazy [__] yeah but my team is
your team so anytime you guys need W
that's cool really all right but I don't
think they're going to do they're going
to tell us how to run our Channel well I
just want a super 73 see so all we
have's got a super 73 from Vegas here
you want to sit on those instead of
chairs I have access to this uh this
panel group at UCI these students and
they go and they they are they are
having their masters and doctorates and
all that stuff in uh in business
Consulting and so they these [__]
students that never ran a business
before going to tell me [__]
what to do no some of these people
already have a career they're getting
and they're getting their stuff yeah if
they're professors and [__] I'm down I
listening to [__] 19-year-old nerd
yeah yeah tell them bro talk they if
you're open to it they'll they'll dig
deep into this business structure and
the revenue and blah blah blah whatever
and they'll they'll figure out what the
what the most efficient process is down
let's go let's go tell me tell me your
like I think the bosses are being
overpaid you're going be like I don't
like this see I'm firing them right
right away yeah shut up idiot yeah
they'll be like why you need six people
and [__] they'll be like fire all these
people like but you're not paying me
he's like that sandwich give me that
sandwich back they're like you do what
for lunch man you got too much of that
Sonora towel man you got to stop eating
that town I saw that on you find out oh
it's finally on the menu nice you are
you going to get it no I don't think I'm
going to I don't think I'm part of that
as your campaign manager okay oh here we
go as your as your campaign manager this
is what I think you should do every time
you have a rally get it catered by
Sonora town snap that you're going to
[__] win
dude you might win a little too hard sh
wi them with food might CA some problems
every like this is I I guarantee you
like burritos will win all campaigns
because everybody loves burritos or
tacos or tacos Mexicans love burritos
Asians love burritos white people love
burritos dude Asians put Asian food in
burritos now freaking crazy and it's
delicious that's what brings California
together anyway they should steal
everything in right cuz like when you do
like if it's it's like a white thing
like a sandwich then you might get like
Asians like [__] no man I want a f right
and then if you do a Asian thing like
like I don't know like a [__] dog
sandwich or some [__] I don't know like
it's too like iin going to eat that [__]
you know I thought you said sandwiches
to white people the dog sandwi put the
dog
dog's I don't know I don't know I don't
know I'm going with this another
sandwich I don't know what sandwiches
are but dog sandwich come so is there
any like uh that you're thinking about
once you're
mayor aside from all the stuff that
people want you to change is there
anything that's close to your heart that
you want to do for the city once you
become mayor yeah it's the so I mean the
ebike policy is is really personal be to
me cuz I'm seeing it like in front of my
eyes I'm like fudge man cuz my kid's
going to get an ebike every it's every
kid has one right and like he he just
started riding bicycles he just finally
learned right um every kid has ebikes
now that's that's the thing like almost
no kids ride regular bikes now they so
lazy that's why big bike's pissed off no
they they are lazy as [__] so you can't
you don't pedal on an ebike you can but
you could just go like like this and go
20 M hour oh so it's like and when the
police come all you do is pedal and they
can't you can't get in trouble for it
wow it's it's a it's a hack cuz there's
no loss so you for if you if you have a
50c and greater bike or motorized bike
you need a permit but if it's all
electric and has pedals you don't need
anything yeah remember when we were kids
like oh like that guy's house
sh if you're going up the hill it's
going to be a [__] you don't want to do
it now they just go and they just go
straight up hill they're going like 45
mil hour free dude they're sick they are
sick though they're dope they're so dope
but it's just you have like a 8-year-old
on it and like they're riding on
sidewalks hella fast you know yeah
there's all these kids in Hawaii that
have like those dirt bike looking ones
and then they just 40 50 of them just
Wheeling down the street dog no wonder
I've been seeing so many kids pedaling
their bikes now I'm thinking about it
but like barely pedaling but going fast
barely fast you notice they're
barely cuz they are going fast they
going faster than your car dude you're
like what the they're going like this
like and they're going like 30 m hour
like
[__] it doesn't look like they're
doing anything oh my gosh yeah the uh
the other thing I'm passion of course is
the Senior Citizen Community I felt like
uh I feel like they're being forgotten
and they're not being supported enough
so we started seniors fight back um like
my so my neighborhood I live in an old
person's neighborhood everybody's like
55 and over and uh one of my neighbors
was getting bullied by a bunch of kids
on ebikes no way [__] up man dude
she's she's walking and uh these kids
are kind of like harassing her in
circling her like freaking vultures yeah
and she's freaking out not even pedling
she's freaking out and I'm not there
right so I'm just like kind of like
narrating how I think it's going in my
head but they're V they're they're
circling her she freaks out she falls
into a bush and then they laugh at her
and then then they drive off that's like
a '90s [__] movie dude
that's like three ninjas man yeah and
and then she's in the bush and then and
she stays there until they leave and
then she walks home and then she shares
with me about this I'm like fudge I'm
not going to tell your name but uh but
I'm like fudge that freaking sucks U did
you got go out looking for ebike boys so
you could kick them while they're riding
it's tough because all of them R ebikes
so it's like you you you you you you you
you which one are you you're like when
I'm there I'm going to incentivize you
guys to take programs to get your
license I know a couple of people that
live in Irvine I'll tell them vote for
you yes please yeah I mean um it's it's
it's a bunch of parts it's crazy it's uh
it's it's it's it's residents of irine
they need a vote and fundraising is huge
too dude people don't realize uh
campaigns are expensive dude it's going
to cost me a mill a quarter million
dollars to run this campaign um so you
got to think those pieces of mail you
see they're about a buck a piece I mean
it's marketing so do you need marketing
dollars yeah it's marketing dollars and
then hiring staff but I bet you
Instagram works better yeah oh we're on
onlines for sure one of my uh one of my
friends uh good friends he's is like my
kid's Godfather he has this company
called hyperb media he's like top 100
like Facebook ads um like uh Spenders
see more teams dude I don't know yeah
dude you guys want to use it dude it's
freaking insane like he could you could
literally log on Instagram right now and
like an ad with my face will be there be
like hey Bart you know Hey Joe and then
that's it and it'll be cheap because
there's not a lot of people targeting
directly just you right so it'll be like
cents on the dollar he'll do it just to
troll you um that's the power of ads cuz
soci social platforms work they get you
in for free they build a mass following
and then they charge you for reach
that's why you know influencers with the
million followers don't have the same
organic reach anymore cuz you have to
pay for the you have to pay for the
reach so before maybe you got like a
million likes now you got like half a
million likes see that's why we got to
pay for our videos oh that's why we have
2 million subscribers and 30,000 views
let's go baby we got to pay for the
videos that we are posting then we'll
get the same views that we did before
yeah but it's that so how much can you
pay to Garner that lose it all all all
Net Zero profit man but yeah man it's
it's crazy just think uh there's 2,000
registered voters in Irvine we send out
I mean you shouldn't do that because you
have to Target the called high high
propensity voters people that are most
likely to vote for you you have grandpas
and grandmas yeah Grand grandpas
grandmas people that voted before and
not voting now dude I have access to all
kinds of crazy data it's insane but just
think 2,000 200,000 pieces of mail
that's $200,000 right there and that's
just one piece of mail that's just one
postcard you know so you have to just I
would have moved there and registered
and voted for you but I'm a Nevada
resident dude I remember dude I I
remember you guys uh threw an event at
UC for the movie you guys made a movie
it was a great turnout 400 people show
up insane that was dope but they're not
students anymore you guys still have a
fall you guys we have a big we have a
big fall in there yeah yeah dude if we
could do a what is it an event there
that would be sick yeah vote for you and
then get all those students to vot team
see the team I need the JK team see he
knows how to do that stuff I don't know
how to do the stuff like that you're the
boss what do you mean I don't I don't
know how to like pull the stuff like
that he just
did well now dude now I'm using AI I'm
like asking everything so you should be
like hey how do I pull this stuff and
then they'll be like well these are the
things that you could
do hey one more question since you've
gotten into this and pulled back the
curtain and the veil of like politics in
your region what's like the Shady thing
that you've
discovered that 90% of people that do it
are doing it for business not for
community service I knew it it was a
harsh reality I sensed that it was a
harsh reality um cuz I came in naive as
F I'm I'm naive in every Circle I jump
into cuz like I've been very fortunate
to have like a good life my parents like
immigrated over here worked hard let me
go to school let me be a cage fighter as
a career like they weren't happy about
it you know they let me fulfill the
American dream you know you know do
whatever you want even though we're
going to yell at you for
it they still Asian so they still have
to yell yeah yeah it's like you did
great but it doesn't mean I'm not going
to yell at
you and uh you know um what was I
getting
at 90% of them is self-interest and
greed so so now I have to wonder there's
there's there's three things I wonder
when it cuz everybody is nice to you and
that's weird when everybody's nice and
welcoming to you right like cuz why not
to be paranoid like um can you work with
me can you use me or do you need to
destroy me and those are the three
things I have to think about when I all
three you know or a combination of all
that you know cuz everybody's been nice
to me but I don't know their true
intentions um but I've been fortunate
because for whatever reason I'm able to
find three or four or more contacts for
each individual I talk to and if I can
get all of them to vouch for them I'm
like oh cool good dude like super good
dude maybe they're nice to you cuz they
know that you could [__] them up yeah
that maybe yeah maybe everyone is nice
to you because of that the fighting has
helped a lot like for everything
politics not politics it's like having
that that part of my life as like a an
ice breaker a a thing that know most
people won't do they're like you know
what I respect you that's tough you know
that's different you know like I could
trust you cuz you're martial arts you
know that stuff um it it really has
opened the doors for me that's 90% of
the network I built through fighting
that's so cool hey early congrats man
hey let's go Ron Ron for May Ron for May
for going to [__] do
he's going to [__] do
[Music]
it